it's great to welcome Neil Ferguson to
the program today he's a historian and
senior fellow at the Hoover Institution
whose new PBS series net world explores
the history and science of networks Neil
it's so great to have you on I
appreciate it thank you David great to
be with you so to start with as as a
historian or an historian as different
people love to argue about that's not
what I want to ask you about but as a
historian is the idea that things
eventually always sort of go back to
feeling the way we remember them feeling
is an inevitability or could we really
now be in in sort of a situation that
that marks a before-and-after that will
be important in the lives of people who
are living right now well yeah that's a
great question to ask an historian a
historian in London it sees an historian
because you don't say the age right up
it's a good question to ask historian
because really we are in a position to
look at past pandemics and see the
extent to which they they changed the
way people lived and and thought we
forget I suspect how frequent pandemics
were in the past and how exposed
populations words are contagious lethal
diseases for example in the nineteenth
century
cholera regularly swept through major
cities on both sides of the Atlantic but
particularly in Europe if you go back a
little further a smallpox was the
problem that people had to deal with in
their early American colonies and even
subsequently and if you want to go all
the way back to the Middle Ages you had
the dreadful problem of bubonic and
pneumonic plague which we call the Black
Death
I think it's fair to say that these
great pandemics with really high
mortality did change things that is to
say people altered their behavior and
they they
didn't interact and the the way they had
before for some time subsequently if you
read Daniel Defoe on the great London
plague of 1665 he talks about the ways
in which people had to become less
trusting of even people that they they
knew and there's an interesting piece of
research on the long-lasting impacts of
the nineteen eighty nineteen influenza
pandemic which really seems to have
affected trust in those countries that
were most badly affected by the pandemic
on the other hand if you look at what
we're going through now it's not as bad
a pandemic as those it's not likely to
kill as large a share of the population
as say the Black Death which killed
perhaps a third of humanity
and even the influenza pandemic of 1918
nineteen killed between two and three
percent of people this is not going to
be by any means as disastrous and so we
probably won't be as as strongly
impacted actually I think the economic
measures we've taken in particular the
lockdowns will probably have had a
bigger impact than the disease itself
precisely because the disease is so
heavily concentrated on certain groups
it's so much more likely to kill elderly
people than the young which makes it
very different from other pandemics so
to cut a very long story short I would
say the best analogy might actually be
with a recent pandemic which operated in
different ways but killed a great many
people hiv/aids hiv/aids changed the way
people behaved sexually and I think
covert nineteen will change the way
people behave socially in somewhat
similar ways especially if there's no
vaccine in a reasonably short timeframe
and that's a big and crucial variable if
there is a vaccine if it's rapidly
discovered if it works really well and
it's generally available this time next
year then I'm not sure that our behavior
will radically change over the long term
but if that vaccine doesn't turn up then
I think you can see big changes in
social behavior somewhat similar to the
changes in sexual behavior that came
after hiv/aids
so you mentioned trust and I'm
interested in hearing a little bit about
you know when we think about the the
affective networks and networks in which
we are
participants are involved in so to speak
what is your sense of the factors that
most are influencing the individual
decisions people are making about do I
go out and protest or not against the
lockdowns
or against police brutality do I wear a
mask or don't I wear a mask etc is it
about who is in your personal Network is
it about the news you consume is it
about what the CDC says if you are part
of a certain network but not part of
another what's your sense of that that's
a great question David the way I think
about this is that there are really two
pandemics going on concurrently one is
the biological pandemic where a new
coronavirus or scoff to spreads around
the world very rapidly and creates all
kinds of dislocations as well as excess
mortality but there's this other
pandemic of information disinformation
misinformation that is going on online
and in some ways some of that contagion
is even more rapid in its spread an
extensive in its spread you're actually
more likely to encounter viral nonsense
about covert 19 than covered 19 itself
because the second pandemic spreads much
more rapidly and you can catch a wrong
idea from the internet which which you
can't do with the virus it requires you
to be in the same physical space as a
carrier so I think the second pandemic
is really interesting because it makes a
huge difference to your experience and
your assessment of risk how you are
networks to the rest of the world if you
are the kind of person who gets
information from mainstream media who
perhaps is quite selective in what you
read perhaps you dip into quality
newspapers in more than one country and
carefully filter outs
click Bayes then you'll form the view as
I would say I have that this pandemic
ain't over and if you are particularly
in an older age group you should not be
rushing into crowd
situations even if they're outdoors but
if you're somebody who gets information
from a very different set of sources
perhaps you're very exposed to the kind
of influences on the far left or the far
right who are very likely to circulate
misinformation and disinformation you
might form the conclusion either that
this thing is over and we should just be
getting right back to normal which is
certainly a widespread view and in some
quarters or you might think well it's
still an issue but I should be much more
outraged about social justice questions
and therefore I should protest because
somehow or other the virus is going to
give me a break if I'm doing something
virtuous so it depends very heavily
where you are in a world where
information is no longer mainly
distributed by terrestrial television
stations as it was say back in the 60s a
world in which information is channeled
through very complex networks in which
influences some of whom you may never
even have heard of have enormous numbers
of followers and can very quickly
persuade them of something that is in
fact quite quite untrue about the nature
of the virus so in thinking about some
of these different ideas and conclusions
that people may integrate into their
beliefs again depending on the networks
in which they participate depending on
the media that they consume I want to
try to link this back to something I
discussed with Jonathan hight when he
was on the program which related to
sometimes it seems as though people may
vote or act against their own personal
interests and one of the ideas that
Jonathan Hite and others have introduced
is that while it that may be true what
may matter to a greater degree is how
much their actions fit into the
interests that whatever orthodoxy or
group they subscribe to has determined
is what's good for them a good example
would be the tea party in the US and
2010 where you had individuals seemingly
supporting a policy that would not be
particularly good for them because they
weren't rich but it was still I don't
know that I want to use their rationale
but we could
understand the behavior better if we
understood how group motivations played
a role does that apply to who is doing
the protesting against lockdowns versus
who is in who is wearing a mask versus
who isn't this sort of group analysis
rather than individual well people have
been thinking about these questions for
a long time
Antonio Gramsci came up with the notion
of false consciousness when he was
trying to explain the failure of the
proletariat to line up in support of
Marxism as an ideology and of course it
was a recurrent feature of European and
American history in the 19th and 20th
centuries that working-class people
stubbornly refused to support socialists
parties so this is quite an old problem
in social science especially for the
United States where socialism was a sort
of non-event until relatively recently
and attracted very little support I
think if you if you're asking do people
act against their own individual
self-interest because of an ideology or
because of a sense of a wider community
the answer is yes they do again and
again and again and that's partly
because of the appeals that can be made
whether it's to your class identity or
your racial identity or your ethnic
identity these appeals are quite potent
and by contrast it's always a little
harder than it it looks to it establish
exactly what your own self-interest is
in economics for many years we tried to
imagine a rational calculating machine
Homo economicus whose goal was just to
maximize utility but as historians we
struggled to find these people they're
really rather unusual and and indeed not
very popular when they do turn up people
like that exist but you tend to find
them running hedge funds rather than
being your everyman so every man is
quite inclined to be swayed by
collective consciousness by ideas of
group loyalty what
comes down to behavior in the pandemic I
think there are there are two distinct
forms of I'll call it irrational
behavior
there's the form that says even although
the number of cases and hospitalizations
is going are going up in my state I'm
still going to go back to work and I'm
gonna go back to the stores and I'm not
gonna wear a mask because the bells of
he'll go tingling for you but not for me
in other words people essentially don't
think they personally are going to get
the virus now that may be because
they're young and they say to themselves
well I've read that it really only kills
the elderly and therefore my risk is
pretty low but what's odd is that we
find quite a lot of older people who say
in surveys that they're in favor of
rapid reopening even before the
pandemics under control in in their area
on the side of people who recently
protested it might be said that outdoors
it's much harder to catch covered 19
than indoors and the most protests are
outdoors therefore there's not much risk
but when you look at the crowds they're
pretty densely packed and the shouting
and we know from the literature that the
key to transmission of SARS cough to is
it's not just talking in a normal way
it's shouting and singing that really
along with coughing and sneezing that
propels the virus from a carrier to
others so there's some risk involved in
going to these protests most of the
protesters are relatively young but I
saw Mitt Romney out in the streets
yesterday wearing a mask prudently but
it's hard to tell I've just looked at
many shots and video clips I wouldn't
say a majority of protesting people have
been wearing masks and I wouldn't say
that they're all as it were young enough
not to worry in any case even if you are
young enough not to be too worried about
SARS cough to you you should be worrying
about the older people that you're going
to meet subsequent to your protest had a
conversation my daughter about this last
night she's distinctly to the left of me
but it eclis but she had wisely resisted
peer group pressure to go on a march in
London on the ground that she would soon
be seeing her mother and grandmother who
are in the vulnerable age group
so that that seemed like a pretty good
example of somebody coming to a good
decision even under peer group pressure
and peer group pressures a huge part of
what's going on here
people may suspect they're doing
something that's not prudent but they
kind of give in to the peer group
pressure I was glad what my daughter
resisted that when it comes to beliefs
about blame and responsibility around
the virus there's definitely some
interesting network effects going on I
was interested to see in your recent
interview with Andy serwer I'll let you
sort of characterize in detail your
position but at least generally speaking
you seem to probably assign less
responsibility to the federal government
and Trump's actions than I would
although I do believe that there have
been unfair accusations also cast at the
federal government which were either
beyond anyone's control or more relevant
to a mayor or a governor for example
what do you think are the unfair
criticisms that are or blame that is
being placed on the president maybe we
can start there
well I think it's worth saying right
away that the primary responsibility for
this pandemic lies with the Chinese
government and also the provincial
authorities in Hebei province who really
criminally fail to deal with the problem
and were slow to admit the extent to
which human to human transmission was
happening a granade imposing travel bans
until it was really much too late so
that's part one part two of the answer
is that the media obsession with
President Trump which he of course
encourages lead I think to a tendency to
overemphasize the president's role in
reality in a crisis of this sort the
agencies that really matter are those
responsible for pandemic preparedness
and that is a part of the Department of
Health and Human Services not just CDC
which has got a lot of the stake but we
have an undersecretary or I think an
Assistant Secretary to be exact at DHHS
whose job this is and who had written
and spoken a good deal on the subject in
fact if you delve into it the federal
bureaucracy had generated any number of
reports on pandemic preparedness and
PowerPoint decks with multiple slides
and indeed on paper the United States
was well prepared for a situation like
this it was just that when it actually
happened back in January and right
through February and into March that the
agencies responsible the people whose
job this was did terribly and we can say
that I think fairly because we can see
where it was done much better in
countries where public health
bureaucracies were quick to respond like
in for example Taiwan or South Korea or
Germany for that matter you don't just
need to look at Asian countries so the
u.s. in common with I'd say also the
United Kingdom did really badly at
dealing with a problem they were
supposed to be ready for making it all
about Trump I think is a mistake which
misunderstands the nature of government
it is not that the president sits there
in the White House with his phone ready
to tweet deciding on everything that's
just not the way it works the federal
government is a hugely complex thing
with multiple agencies more than 60 in
total and there is an agency who has
this job and they failed and not nearly
enough has been written about that in my
view this is not to say Trump did great
he did quite badly his decision-making
was erratic he had some good instincts
like we have to do something about
people coming in from China but it came
much too late to make any difference at
all at the end of January and I think
instinctively Trump felt that lockdowns
were a mistake which i think was right
too because it was an incredibly blunt
instrument to deal with the contagion
and not necessary if in fact you've done
the right things early on so you know
you you can't say it's all his fault
I think that's a great mistake but nor
can you say he's done a great job I mean
in the end the the buck stops with the
president the United States as Harry
Truman said long ago and so one can't
say well it was all the faults of dhhs
not the president's fault he's the
president ultimately the buck stops with
him there's no question that the United
States has handled this pandemic very
much worse than
should have very much worse than other
comparable countries and that is why we
have the highest death toll and may well
end up with a very high excess mortality
rate by the end of the year so maybe
we're not actually that far I mean in
hearing you lay it out it seems like
some of this is about the president as
the per you know HHS run by Alex a czar
who early on thought it was a good idea
to port a former Labradoodle dealer in
charge of the day-to-day okay that was a
bad decision
he is Trump's pick to run HHS so a lot
of this seems to be the semantics of
Trump's delegation versus Trump's
actions I mean I think the biggest
critique certainly would be when you
look at South Korea and the u.s. finding
our first cases within hours of each
other
South Korea rapid test development fever
clinics isolation contact tracing that
happened six weeks later or it started
to happen in a serious way six weeks
later the testing capacity was a joke
I do think you know you can't blame
Trump for a hundred thousand one hundred
and ten thousand deaths of course there
was probably a period there I would say
around you know aggressively March tenth
less aggressively March twenty-fifth
were the requests for a coordinated
50-state stay at home that would be long
over by now had it been done from the
start and we wouldn't have what we now
have rolling opening and closing Florida
and Texas spiking well fortunately here
in Massachusetts were doing well that
certainly was a lost opportunity for
Trump and I would even say it was a lost
opportunity from a campaign standpoint I
think that he has now suffered greatly
because he didn't do some of these
things that may have been economically
unpopular at first but would likely have
him with a much higher than 38% approval
today I wonder if you agree it's
difficult on that I mean my sense is
that by mid-march it was it was too late
and that blanket shelter-in-place orders
would not really have had a huge impact
by that stage other than in fact to
magnify the
Shok let me reiterate the key decision
points were in January as soon as it
became clear there was a problem yeah
and right into February when President
Trump and many others in the
administration were downplaying the
threat and not only president Trump
remember at the end of January when
Trump called for a travel ban on Chinese
passengers coming into the US he was
widely criticized in the liberal media
accused essentially of racism and there
were multiple articles at that time in
liberal circles saying it's just the flu
in fact you should worry much more about
the flu and for me as somebody who was
writing no this really isn't the flu
this is very much more serious it was
maddening to see such ill-informed
rubbish being published so widely there
was a bipartisan failure to recognize
the scale of the threat that went on
right into February I can remember being
in Washington in mid-february trying to
convince people in the administration
this thing is real you have got to do
something and you particularly have to
tell the president to stop saying there
is no threat to the United States it's
just gonna disappear so it was it was
then that I think the really disastrous
mistakes were made by mid-march they had
been insouciant for so long that they
were actually thrown into panic by
another Neil Ferguson it's worth
clarifying that I'm not him any il
Ferguson the epidemiologist at Imperial
College London who published a report on
March 16th saying that if you didn't
have lockdowns 2.2 million people were
going to die in the United States and
half a million in the UK and both the
London and Washington governments
flipped when they saw this as did many
people who saw the report or read about
it and we went from total insouciance to
total panic this was really the worst of
both worlds because we had dithered
around when we should have been taking
early action and then we did a bunch of
extremely blunt instrument measures like
shelters and place orders and economic
lock downs that it doesn't seem to me
have radically changed the spread or
slowed the spread of the virus social
distancing was something that mattered a
lot when people adopted that even not at
the order of the state it had a big
impact the lock downs have clearly done
much more
harm than public health good so as I
said we've ended up with this kind of
worst of both worlds and it's not over
and for me the depressing thing is
seeing people behaving all over the
country as if it is over in in defiance
of the reality that if you just look at
numbers of confirmed cases there are
second waves already in about a dozen
states it's already happening and let me
ask ya so the last thing I wanted to
touch on was for a while I've been
fearing that there was going to be a
point at which it's going to be sort of
unclear what each person should be doing
here in Massachusetts today outdoor
dining gets to open and then this is
phase 2a and then we're going to get to
phase 2b where something else can happen
and you know I don't know I'm in my
mid-30s I'm probably fine to go and sit
outside at a restaurant but should I do
it and is it if you need a mask is this
is that a signal that I shouldn't be
doing it or that what do you make of
this phase now that could last really it
could last until there's a vaccine I
don't know how long it's going to last
where there's going to be a lot of
needing to sort of figure out for
oneself what is the appropriate behavior
yes I think you're right to feel
confused and uncertain because mixed
policy signals at the national and state
level have created exactly that sense of
confusion all over the country and this
goes back to what we were talking about
earlier when people are uncertain but
get their information from let's say
more sensationalistic sources then they
will take action that is in fact not
going to help and might even harm them
hydroxychloroquine for example is an
example of something that was touted as
a remedy not just by the president but
by many other people but the only really
good scientific research on theirs
suggests that it has no real
prophylactic effect and it's quite
harmful if you are suffering seriously
from covert 19 so as people try to work
out what to do they're battling against
a combination of poor quality public
information from the government I mean I
think our public health bureaucracy has
failed at
Communications level by the way really
interesting piece on this subject in the
New York Times just about a week ago
going through what exactly went wrong at
CDC it's well worth reading unlike many
things in the New York Times and and it
actually shows a classic pathology of a
burek bureaucratic organization very
hierarchical very slow-moving and easily
bullied by the White House when the
going got tough it is a very very stark
illustration of a problem that the great
physicist Richard Feynman identified
long ago in the case of the Challenger
Space Shuttle disaster
it's the mid-level bureaucracy that's
often the problem in disasters like this
so we as individuals are getting poor
information from the public authorities
and even worse information from the
internet what are we going to do
well we have to make sure that we read
carefully what is out there that is
reputable
that is to say has some solid basis in
scientific research and on that basis my
advice to you is you probably fine to go
and eat outside in Massachusetts on a
nice day you should wear a mask and you
should really keep your distance from
from other people as far as you can just
to be on the safe side because
Massachusetts is a state where there are
still quite a high level of cases of
code 19 being diagnosed that everyday
would I advise you to go into a crowded
office or to take a crowd form of public
transport no I'd say avoid those things
avoid any crowded indoor space
especially if people are shouting or
singing so forget choir practice and if
somebody says let's have a reopening
party come on round to my place up
lightly decline because those are very
likely that super spreader events that
we're going to get in the coming weeks
and months that will keep this pandemic
going in the United States for much
longer than was necessary seems
eminently reasonable I would say we've
been speaking with Neil Ferguson he is a
historian and the new PBS series net
world explores the history and science
of networks Neil really appreciate your
time today
thanks David it's beautiful
enjoy that enjoy that dinner that's the
problem that's the that's the logistical
issue I will figure it out thank you
thanks